السيد.  أشكرك السفير على وقتك
الليلة مع هذه التطورات المفاجئة من
الواضح أن العالم بأسره يركز على
هذه القصة عندما تنظر إلى ما
حدث هنا هل كان هذا إعلان
حرب في الواقع كان عملاً حربياً
من جانب الولايات المتحدة ضد
الشعب الإيراني - بدأت الولايات المتحدة
حربًا اقتصادية ضد الشعب الإيراني
في مايو 2018 عندما قررت خطة الرئيس
ترامب الانسحاب من
الاتفاق النووي ، وبدأت
سياسة الضغط الأقصى ضد الإيرانيين ،
مما أدى إلى مزيد من الضغط الاقتصادي على
إيران وهم.  حتى
اليوم ، فتحوا فصلاً جديدًا في
هجومهم على الاتحاد من خلال
اغتيال الأسد لواحد من أعز
جنرالاتنا المحبوبين ليس فقط في إيران
ولكن أيضًا في دول المنطقة ،
وكان ذلك كما قلت فصلاً جديدًا
وهو ما يرقى إلى بدء حرب
ضد إيران ، لذلك عندما تقول
بمثابة حرب بمثابة عمل من أعمال الحرب ، فإن الكلمات التي
استخدمتها للسفير باشا للمحامي الأعلى
إيه زعيم إيراني اليوم قال أو
تعهد بالانتقام الشديد وكلماته الأخرى
كانت انتقاما قاسيا لما
يسميه المجرمين الذين ارتكبوا هذا
الهجوم الأمريكيين فماذا يعني ذلك
إذا كنت ستنتقم
من عمل حربي؟  هي تلك
الحرب كما قلت ، لقد صنعت الولايات المتحدة بالفعل
حربًا ضد إيران ليس فقط
حربًا اقتصادية ولكن أيضًا شيء يتجاوز
ذلك من خلال اغتيال الهند أو كبار
الجنرالات الذين يحزنهم
الناس في إيران وفي المنطقة ، لذلك
لا يمكننا إغلاق منطقتنا  عيون على ما
حدث الليلة الماضية
بالتأكيد سيكون هناك انتقام هناك
بالفعل انتقام قاسٍ سوف
تتصرف إيران بناءً على اختيارها
الخاص والوقت والمكان
وتقرر حقًا ذلك من خلال القيام بذلك أريد أن
أسألك عن ذلك لأنه عندما
حدث هذا  لم يقل الرئيس ترامب الليلة الماضية
أنه كان يستهدف شخصًا
آخر ، وحدث أن الجنرال سليماني كان
هناك ، وقال إنه كان هو
واستهدفناه وقتلناه ولم يكن هناك وكلاء هناك.  لا يوجد عذر
يجعله يمتلكها ، فسوف يرد أراس على
أنه نفس الطريقة التي تستهدف بها إيران
الولايات المتحدة ، فأنا لست في وضع يسمح لي
بالخوض في تفاصيل
ما سيحدث عندما تتصرف
في Venge ولكن ما أفعله  يمكن أن أقول لك
ذلك من خلال استهداف أحد كبار
جنرالاتنا لتأكيد منا
الالتزامات الدولية باستخدام
الفضاء الأرضي لدولة مستقلة
العراق دولة ذات سيادة ثم
الرئيس ، أنا آسف أن رئيس
وزراء ذلك البلد قد أدان
عمله العدواني من قبل الولايات المتحدة ، أعني
أنه ينبغي عليهم توقع أي شيء
نتيجة لذلك  هذا العدوان